comments to bring you some breaking news
Sky News has obtained a CCTV image of a
man who's believed to have been arrested
on suspicion of murdering free people in
Nottingham
well the image is believed to show the
suspect as he looked for a way into a
residential home which houses vulnerable
and homeless people in the city
Witnesses say that the man arrived at
the property just after 4 a.m yesterday
morning well let's get more now on this
new development for my correspondent Tom
Parmenter he was in Nottingham for us
and Tom what can you tell us about what
those who experienced this have had to
say
well this is as you say the first image
of the suspect in this investigation the
man the police believe uh was
responsible for the series of attacks
they are not looking for anyone else at
this stage and the image shows as you
can see a man standing outside this
property a residential home in the north
of the city and he this was recorded
shortly after 4 a.m yesterday morning
still quite light very light summer
evenings at the moment so even though it
was 4 a.m the picture is relatively
light and you can see the man standing
outside the building and as we say this
is a home that houses vulnerable and
homeless people in the city of
Nottingham and he tried to climb into a
window of that property
and one of the residents inside has told
Sky News that he realized someone was
trying to get into that bedroom and he
punched the man forcing him back away
from the window falling down to the
ground and the seeleyhurst house
residential home have told us that they
are working and cooperating with the
detectives who are trying to piece
together the series of attacks in
Nottingham and that they cannot yet give
any explanation as to why the suspected
attacker in Nottingham was at their
property in the early hours of yesterday
morning they simply don't think that
he's ever stayed there before and they
don't know of any clear connection
between him and any of the residents
inside that residential home but of
course they are clearly shaken now
knowing what else happened in in the
early hours of Tuesday morning here on
ilkeston road where the two students
were stabbed having been returning from
a night out in the city towards the end
of their summer term and of course that
other attack at magdala Road where we
know the third victim Ian Coates died a
school caretaker and that magdala Road
location is quite close to this
Residential Care Home and the suspect
was seen with a black backpack
then going from that Residential Care
Home towards magdala Road where the
third victim Ian Coates was found and
where of course we also know that that
white van was stolen and taken into the
city center driven recklessly through
the middle of the city past the Royal
Theater
in the middle of Nottingham hitting
three pedestrians critically injuring
one of them we understand that
pedestrian is still in hospital
receiving intensive care for his
injuries but this new image of the
suspected Knife Man in Nottingham
we're only able to show you that for the
first time now and as I say the police
are liaising with that Residential Care
Home where that image was recorded in
the early hours of Tuesday as they try
to piece together the precise timeline
of what happens in what is a murder
inquiry of course they are still sharing
information with their counter terrorism
colleagues as they explained yesterday
but there's still very much a murder
investigation being led by the
Nottinghamshire police force who are
aware of the CCTV that we are sharing
with you this lunch time and it is the
first image of the man suspected of
being responsible for the attack that
left three people dead and a city just
stunned and particularly the student
population in this city at the loss of
two bright
talented and highly respected 19 year
old colleagues families of course
devastated by that but this first image
of the suspected attacker taken from
that Residential Care Home and a key
part now of the police investigation